[Music]
the night sky lights up explosions ring
out across the city of iril in Northern
[Music]
Iraq Iran says it hit what it describes
as spy headquarters used by Israel's
intelligence agency Mossad and
Gatherings of anti-iranian terrorist
groups at least five missiles struck
Targets near the US Consulate and
residential areas in the administrative
capital for the Iraqi Kurdish Regional
government daytime video shows some of
the
destruction Iraqi Kurdish Regional
authorities say several people were
killed and others injured in the
attacks many of the offices of terrorist
organizations and the Mad are very close
to the US Consulate because that they
feel protected but the Iranians were
sending both striking these targets
because unfortunately Northern Iraq is
heavily infiltrated they were both
striking these targets but also they
were telling the Americans they were
sending a message that our missiles are
very precise and we're not afraid to
Target these offices these bases near
your building the US condemned the
attacks calling them a reckless and
imprecise set of strikes in recent days
the US and UK have been targeting Hy
bases in Yemen in retaliation for
attacks on cargo ships in the Red Sea
the hes say the vessels belong or are
connected to countries supporting Israel
Washington says Iran supplies the
houthis with weapons Anar has been
putting pressure on his ships going to
Israeli ports to build on more pressure
to end this this Holocaust and of course
the resistance in Iraq has also been
active to put pressure on the Americans
to end this but uh so so far we haven't
seen deescalation we're only seeing
escalation Iraq called the attacks a
violation of its sovereignty and vowed
to respond using all legal measures
including filing a complaint at the UN
Security
Council Iran has carried out attacks in
Northern Iraq before targeting what it
says are armed Iranian opposition groups
but these latest strikes come as fears
grow internationally about a wider
escalation in violence in response to
Israel war on Gaza a war that Israel
says is far from over Charles statford
aljazera
well let's discuss this latest
developments further now with lahib
higuel who's a senior Iraq analyst said
the international crisis group is
joining us from stockolm thank you very
much for being with us Li so Iran
carrying out this attack in the largest
sphere of where we are in the region at
the moment with with the war in Gaza how
significant and how concerning is this
action by the Iranians
it is of course significant considering
that Iran chose to itself um strike
targets inside Iraq which it so far
hasn't done um the escalation that we've
seen with the US and Iraq has mainly
been conducted by Iraqi groups that are
aligned with Iran um so this is
definitely a step further although it is
important to uh point out that it was
not uh an attack directed at the us
assets right the Iranian revolutionary
guard said that they they targeted spy
headquarters uh and what they called
anti-iran so-called terrorist groups in
the Kurdish region of
Iraq is is you know is that area of Iraq
heavily infiltrated with these groups
the mosad for example as Iranians
suggest why that specific
area so this is not the first time uh
that they have struck a BAL uh with
these motivations uh there was a similar
strike in March 2022 when other
prominent Kurdish businessmen's house
was targeted um and they used the same
uh motivation that it was a strategic
Center where where mad operated uh there
is no evidence for for this however um
but clearly uh Iran is trying to show
that it is willing to strike back for
escalation that we see in other parts of
the region uh and this is an easy target
that is geographically close yeah an
easy target you say how might the Iraqis
respond and what does an escalation mean
for the stability of
Iraq the Iraqi um uh government has
responded the foreign uh Ministry has
called up the Iranian Ambassador uh the
Kurdistan Regional government has of
course condemned the attack uh both uh
and central government see it as a
violation of Iraqi sovereignty um but in
terms of escalation in Iraq I'm not sure
that this is the most significant uh
type of attack that we've seen we've
seen tit fortat attacks between uh us
and and Iranian back groups in Iraq that
have taken place in Baghdad and uh in
the South uh of the country and in many
ways I think that that sort of
escalation for the stability of Iraq uh
is more concerning uh even though this
is uh a blatant violation of Iraqi
sovereignty including the Kurdistan
region interesting to talk to you about
this thank you so much for your time
lahib hiel from the international crisis
group joining us there from Stockholm
thank you